i have a
confession to make right off the bat i
don't know what you were doing at 16 but
i'm a really big fan of harry potter and
was waiting way
too long to receive my letter inviting
me to hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
i could have gone for six form i was
also waiting
for an invitation to the jedi temple
or a tap on the shoulder to invite me to
the x-men
i was that kid when i was 16 years old
i got my wish i was taken
into a doctor's office and told that i
am in fact
part of a group of people who are still
largely invisible and misunderstood
i am intersex that's my superpower
for many of you in this room it'll be
the first time you've even heard the
word into sex
intersex is anatomy it refers to people
who are born with
one or more of a variation of sex
characteristics
that's your genitals your hormones your
chromosomes
that fall outside of the traditional
conceptions
of male and female bodies
in other words the most basic assumption
we've made about our species what we're
taught in schools
that sex is binary just male
and female is not correct
like most things in this world it is
much more complicated than that
intersex people who fall outside of this
full sex binary have always existed
throughout human history like the
wizards of harry potter we are
pretty much invisible some of us don't
even know
that we are intersex like the
x-men some of our traits are obvious at
birth
and others turn up around the time when
puberty is
supposed to kick in
when we find out we are intersex some of
us believe we are the
only ones in the world
me specifically i have
xy chromosomes which you may have
understood to be
typically male i was also born
with gonads instead of ovaries
standing here on this stage would have
been my
worst nightmare only five years ago
it would have been impossible
i used the metaphor of the superhuman
but really we are just like you
intersex people are thought to make up
to 1.7
of the population that means more
depending on where you are in the world
but
you get the picture we are in front of
you getting coffee we are
sat next to you on the train we are
swiping you left and right on dating
apps
so why haven't you heard of us
if we are so common why don't you see us
how has the world responded to us
we often think of disciplines like
medicine and the law
as supposedly neutral immune to bias
the law is reason free from passion
the doctor's hippocratic oath states
that warmth
sympathy and understanding may outweigh
the surgeon's knife
or the chemist pill in truth
these disciplines that touch our lives
are impressive but they are filled with
our prejudices
they are not immune just as we are not
immune
to the effects of that prejudice which
can be
devastating in medicine
intersex babies who are born with
ambiguous
genitalia are routinely operated on
without consent without
medical need irreversibly
in order to make their healthy anatomy
appear more normal
this is before they've even said their
first words
indicated a sexuality or a gender
identity
many people are never told the truth
about their intersex traits
and those who are are instructed often
not to tell anyone secrecy
is enforced and shame is a close shadow
in the law intersex people fall outside
of
categorization and more importantly
protection this concerns the
banal tasks if you can imagine the
number of forms you filled out that you
had to check
m or f on to
lacking protection under any law
specifically the gender recognition or
equality act
and intersex people cannot correct
the sex classification they've been
given at birth
unless they declare they are transgender
after decades of activism
these life-altering problems are
starting to be addressed
so why does this matter to those of you
who aren't intersex who don't have
variations of sex characteristics
i imagine many people in this audience
have in the privacy of their own
bathrooms
wondered am i labia too long
are my testicles uneven is my penis too
small
is my vagina too wide or too shallow
nothing that hurts or
gets in the way just aesthetically
are mine normal
i imagine that many people in this
audience
have those small concerns but
generally go about their lives not
thinking about it
these variations in our bodies like the
color of our eyes
or the size of our feet rarely affect
our health materially
to put it another way to give you an
idea of the intersex experience
what if when you were an infant your
parents or your doctors
looked at your labia your penis your
testicles and thought
they're healthy feeling
but they're not normal
even before you knew what you wanted to
do with them where you know want to put
them
what if they went so far
as to assign you a different sex
based off these measurements
and then they lied to you about what
they'd done
what if these surgeries sterilized you
what if they resulted in immense pain
and scarring
what if you had to take medicine for the
rest of your life
to replace the healthy organs they took
away
and you had to pay for that medicine
yourself
and then every time you went to a
doctor's office
for a cold you were questioned about
your sex life your gender identity
what your private parts look like and
then
more doctors and medical students were
invited
to add to these questions ask you to
drop your trousers or submit to an
unnecessary
medical exam
this is a picture of what is happening
to the intersex community people like me
every day around the world
our community is not anti-medicine
or anti-surgery we are for the right
to make decisions about our bodies
and our lives the current approach
to intersex people stems from a now
debunked academic study from a man who
over
50 years ago believed that you could
raise a child
in any gender by changing their genitals
never telling them and reinforcing that
gender over
and over again it also stems from
referring to
healthy intersex variations as
abnormal or disordered
this makes sense if you refer to
something as a disorder
suggest there's a fix it also stems
the fear and stigma of being intersex
from homophobia transphobia
sexism and ultimately our colonial past
i am not here to say that the categories
of men and women
don't exist i'm saying like most things
in this world
it is more complicated than that
the world is complex and we can choose
to see that as beautiful
or we can choose to continue to deny
the existence of that complexity push
people into artificial binary boxes
fix what isn't broken and restrict
our own field of vision
one of the challenges that intersex
people face today
is making ourselves visible
and making ourselves safe at the same
time
by that i mean we are appealing to the
humanity of lawmakers
to make us safe whilst
putting ourselves into the public eye
sharing our stories
trying to build community with people
like us
even when it isn't safe to do so
for parents of intersex children
listening and watching
for those in the audience who may become
the guardians of intersex people
i want you to know i love my life
but it has not been free of issue
especially in relation to being intersex
no life is free of issue all coins have
two sides
the one side i have been
humiliated in doctor's offices
i have stood in front of prospective
partners
and felt afraid and so not good enough
i have watched other women pass me in
the street and imagine the ways
that they were more women than me more
human than me
i have questioned whether i have a place
in this world
on the other i have been
deeply loved for everything
that i am in friendship and romantically
i have learnt compassion and empathy
for a wider range of society
i have taken the time to love my body
and not judge the bodies of others
i have developed a strength and a hope
that would have been impossible without
this
particular life
the instinct to protect children is
instinctive
and it's admirable but the truth is
that love acceptance and refusing to
bathe that child in shame
will protect them more than trying to
fix something
that isn't broken
this is why it is in our interest to
protect intersex people
and make them visible for as long
as societies reinforce one form of
acceptable
of normal everyone will face
insecurity for being different in any
way
simply trying to erase variation
difference build shame
being intersex has not materialized the
powers that i wished for as a teenager
beyond being able to see where this
false sex binary
harms us all
it is my belief that if intersex people
can gain equality can be seen
can be accepted and can be loved
then we all will thank you
you